hallo und herzlich willkommen wir heute
zu einem neuen video von mir wie er also
die publisher von kiefer 18 haben mich
und ich habe gesehen dass wir sehr gern
fifa spielen also ich seit fifa nur
sechs sätze sei tiefer 04 im nämlich
auch schon damals eingeladen die auch
nicht
[Applaus]
oder anders gefragt hätte luca hättet
ihr bock mal video zu fifa zu machen
also vielleicht ein video auf dem kanal
konzept nur noch lange kanal wo ihr euch
ein team zusammenstellen auf jeden fall
findet ihr jetzt gerade schon in der
video beschreibung ein video
eingeblendet bin ich mit gewissen der
mitte sein live danke dafür
hier findet auf jeden fall in der
beschreibung ein link ein gelände zu dem
video was wir auch selbst kanal schon
aufgenommen haben dort haben wir nämlich
auch schon text gezogen und zwar sind ex
mehr oder weniger die sammelkarten
früher also man sieht packs für eine
ingame währung dafür bekommt man spiele
und meine güte
meiner hat auch er weder unsere spieler
dass wir auch sehr viel skandal gezogen
haben dass sie dir in seinem video dann
mehr gibt es eigentlich nichts zu sagen
also ist halt oben werde video
eingeblendet weil es hat eine
kooperation mit fifa ist und ich würde
sagen sind nicht so auf jeden fall
sprach das heißt wir ziehen jetzt texten
fifa game los geht's schlafsack ist
abgeschlagen dagegen jetzt entscheiden
da es dass ich jetzt gerade ist mein
team meine damen und herren ihr seht
schon ich habe ultra gute spieler am
start da ich halt kein team haben wir
meine damen und herren müssen wir jetzt
erstmal hexen und mir ein team aufbauen
und das passiert im heutigen video und
wir schauen wir ob derzeitigen welche
kassen gibt es gibt nämlich derzeit
seltene gold im ersten direkt 100 oder
wir auf keinen fall ich werde ich so
verstehe dass kein platz
lasst nicht hingucken lassen sich in
kurzer zeit nicht im kreis offenes ea
hat uns übrigens kostenlos fifa points
gegeben also ihr seht schon 59 1650
belieben wir haben schon von euren puls
bekommen mein mann meine fifa spiel ist
einfach 500 euro wert
ja und ich werde den schüler haben die
fahrt nicht dass ich mir gedacht bei den
drei okay alles fürs erste auch nicht
schlecht ich will halt ein englisches
team machen und nicht galatasaray oder
argentinien schmelzer wird in dein team
passen sie unbedingt den habe ich vor
zwei wochen erst getroffen
das 2 meine damen und herren ich krieg
wieder auf 500 fifa points und sich
[Applaus]
schon gucken
gegen becker wie nennt man leichter eine
kirschbaum parteichefs
vettel was du da warst ja ich wollte dir
gerade anbieten das nächste taxi direkt
wie vereine ist übrigens fragen wieso
dieser controller schon so ein bisschen
kaputt ist
man hat den koffer gegen die kontrolle
geworden ja ja die englisch verhalten
meint überall tapete aber transport ist
damit nur bedingt folgen
bruno später nachdem ist salat benannt
worden
das nächste packard der andere
controller ziehen
das klingt sinnvoll ich habe mich immer
noch was man dann noch mal denken viele
das sind schon bereit war
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
unser team ist übrigens nicht nur aus
den spielern bestätige ziehen sondern
wir werden die auch spieler natürlich
auch ein bisschen verkaufen anderen
spieler kauft euch dann falls am ende
des videos
unser aktuelles team dann vorstellen mit
dem er gegen den anderen antreten werden
ist bereit
meine damen und herren ich darf
ankündigen dass ich jetzt einen scream
spieler ziehen werde das ist ein screen
spieler luca schön dass du fragt sie was
ist ja hinter dem spieler ist ein hoch
bewerteter fifa spieler für einen kurzen
zeitraum
aha bei halloween haben einige spieler
halten upgrade bekommen das sind böse
dann beispielsweise anstatt 880 jetzt
irgendwie 91 hat dagegen die so was halt
und deswegen denen sich hierzu ein
[Applaus]
das ist kein scream spieler okay dann
fangen wir an drei holte der portugiese
junge hat er wohl trecker dabei das
große pech für 500 points ist jetzt
gerade abgelaufen weil man davon nur
fünf stück ziehen darf er das limitiert
auf die anzahl ist aber jetzt ziehen wir
das premium elektro spieler zeit dass er
nicht nur spieler drin
so kommt man deutsche mittelfeld getan
jorge tito schade er ist neues team kiel
hält sich die gurte großen 72 pace gehen
klaffen innenverteidiger das letzte
premium elektronik meine damen und
herren ich klicke daraus ziehen danach
nach diesem pack sehen wir uns wieder
wenn wieder krasse tags am start sind
ich würde sagen jetzt meine damen und
herren der vier russen der sich als ist
ein japaner es ist kagawa wahrscheinlich
ja ticket ist das die perfekte
bundesliga sport united defektem
einheiten laufen wir machen der die
architektin meint ihr 39 in form besser
besser smaghi
die kostet 22
das richtig obwohl er richtig gut werden
das hier war jetzt das letzte was wir
für heute gezogen haben ich glaube die
luft packe ich mir schon mal mit rein
der ist auch in der premier league
vertreten das heißt wir sehen uns jetzt
an einem anderen tag wieder und wieder
pack sind nur wenige minuten später wir
haben gerade erfahren dass es gerade die
mega sexy alive gibt die sind wirklich
hier irgendwie vor ein paar minuten er
reingekommen und in denen sind 30
objekte drin von denen und 26 grad und
18 selten
das heißt da hat sie mir wieder ein paar
wochen muss ich vor allem das ist bisher
das kostet etwas ist angeblich
okay okay ich dachte
also wir glaube ich wieder einer genau
ok ok
der kaffee passt gut in mein team ist
sich das gibt mir ein screenshot ist er
willkommen
peya platt klappen aufkommt oder
durchschnittlich 686 erwartest du
kriegst immer nur premier league spieler
das weiß habe ich noch meine damen und
herren das hier ist das vorletzte tag
was wir von den kassen ziehen können das
ist wieder ein zum hinstellen
deutschland innenverteidiger
mustafi von da an der trasse kommt
safety freunde
stimmst du gerade
das halte ich in mein team und ich habe
in den letzten tagen auf jeden fall noch
sehr sehr viele packs gezogen special
pack spa normale premium gold und haben
das was sie da drin hatten teils
verkauft hat sind unsere teams gepackt
und jetzt präsentiere ich euch mein team
mit dem ich gegen apple antreten werde
das duell kommt in ein paar tagen online
also abonniert den kanal hier und wartet
ab mein studium besteht aus agüero der
hat unglaublich krasse tempodribblings
und schuss wehrte dann habe ich als
linken flügel theorie als icon aber nur
in leih spieler mit dem kann ich jetzt
also nur fünf spiele spielen dann habe
ich auf den rechten flügel illian
einfach mega fix mega gut im dribbling
dann habe ich als zentrum ich weiß dass
hier ist eine zentrale mittelfeld
position wenn ich ein spiel starte habe
ich die formation 433 dann werde ich
allerdings direkt wenn ich im spiel drin
wenn die formation auf 4-2-3-1 umstellen
einfach damit die chemie der spieler
nicht darunter leidet also ein bisschen
inside tipp da habe ich auf jeden fall
erikson mega kranke pass wert und dann
agieren quasi gui und macao hier als dmc
haben einfach klasse defensivwerte also
die hauen alles vor der abwehr wegfalls
des sippel trotzdem mit irgendeiner
situation schaffen sollte bis zu meiner
abwehr vorzustoßen habe ich immer noch
in rio ferdinand als icon er hat 89
defensive seppel probiert erst gar nicht
als einen innenverteidiger häufig
kuscheln ihr habt ja gesehen habe ich
gezogen
auch war rechten verteidigerposition
habe ich bock hat jetzt einfach mega fix
noch verlinken position habe ich denn
rost im tor patrick hab ich halt auch
gezogen hat der auswechselbank habe ich
noch bravo alexis sanchez der wird halt
dann für ihr einkommen wenig theorie bis
zu dem spiel gegen bin ich mir haben
sollte als hensel spieler wird
allerdings nicht in meinem team rein
kommen weil der kein premier league ist
dann habe ich auch an staaten walker
kann ich den wechsel habe ich hier noch
mustafi bisschen die deutsche ehre
hochhalten mach es habe ich hier noch
fand ich aber bisher nicht so gut als
mit dem gespielt haben morath an noch
als auswechslungen für akw- roloff der
reservebank habe ich noch hier ära der
ein bisschen offensiv ein bisschen mehr
offensiv agieren kann als sitzen
bagayoko und dann habe ich hier noch
continue coutinho auch krass da wird ja
derzeit irgendwie bei barca und real bei
allen gehandelt aber ich glaube ihr habt
jetzt um ihr team verstanden in diesem
video also es geht halt quasi darum dass
man text sieht und war sie in den text
verschiedene items sind die kabinen
wieder an die eigene mannschaft packen
oder halt verkaufen und sich davon
andere spieler kaufen
ich habe auf jeden fall einige spieler
behalten die ich gezogen habe allerdings
auch sehr viel verkauft weil die einfach
nicht in meinen in mein team reingepasst
haben oder ich die spieler schon hatte
und davon habe ich mir das teil dieses
team zusammengestellt ich bin auf jeden
fall sehr sehr zufrieden damit dort will
ich jetzt sagen meine damen und herren
wenn euch dieses video hier gefallen hat
er das gern man like da spielt er selber
fifa schreibt gerne in die kommentare
und sonst würd ich sagen sehen uns die
tage wieder wenn ich's apple auf diesem
kanal hier so eine richtige abreibung
verpassen werde